are you friends with Steven Spielberg
we're very friendly we every like three
or four years we get together I'll go
over to his house or we'll go out and
and and have dinner and and then we just
talk for hours and hours and hours on on
end yeah I went duck hunting with him
once you're kidding it was actually
interesting it was in 94
I guess it was 95 because the Oscars
were coming up and Stephen called me up
and goes hey Clinton how would you like
to go duck hunting with me and Bob
zemeckis and John malias all right the
[ __ ] yeah I would love to do that I'd
never been duck hunting before uh uh um
but part of Steven's idea was one I mean
I was this the new kid in town and they
were all really impressed with with Pulp
Fiction but one of the things that
Stephen wanted to do is look you and Bob
semekis are going to be in competition
the whole rest of this year with Forrest
Gump and Pulp Fiction so before that
competition starts maybe it would be
nice that we all go off and do something
together so we just kind of keep in mind
that you know uh uh we're all artists
and we're all friendly what a nice
thought what a nice thing for him to do
and the Spielberg said something that
night
that that day said something that I
hadn't heard anybody
say it quite that way before and made
everything seem a little realer
um
I knew that when it came to the Oscars
for best original screenplay that I was
uh you know we were probably
um
the most likely ones to win for Pulp
Fiction at that time
Uber he Prides himself on understanding
the business and so he's talking to me
very pragmatically so we're walking
through a forest or something and he's
just you know he's right in front of me
now I'm falling behind him
and he's like so here's what's going to
happen at the Oscars and we haven't even
been nominated yet okay it's just gonna
happen so here's what's going to happen
at the Oscars I don't think you're going
to win the Oscar I think it's going to
be uh Bob who's going to win best
picture and I think it's going to be Bob
who's going to win uh best director in
fact I'm pretty sure of it uh but I do
think you will win uh best original
screenplay and then he stopped and then
turned around and looked at me and goes
second movie little gold man not too bad
I started walking and by the way that's
another nice thing kind of like you know
set your expectations a little bit lower
so you're not disappointed yeah yeah and
if you don't get it yeah you don't get
all caught up in this whole uh you know
uh covering the table kind of thing or
how just easy it is to get caught up in
a competition of something but him just
saying second movie little gold man not
too bad
even calling it the little gold man all
right that's really great was [ __ ]
great